thank you very much indeed Gerry thank
you all very very much indeed I always
feel whenever I'm emceeing something or
moderating something particularly in New
York I think immediately of that great
moderator I'm sure you all remember we
used to collect his mistakes I remember
the one and only mr. Ed Sullivan do you
remember some of those marvels I used to
collect them some of those marvelous
introductions he did I remember one
where he said do you remember that one
where he said here they are ladies and
gentlemen three young ladies from
Detroit The Supremes tell me girls where
are you from I mean what do you say we
on the David fry on the David Frost show
we used to have on a Monday night
shell-shocked victims of EDS
introductions the night before I
remember one day we had Jack Jones on
and he'd been on on a Monday night and
he'd been on Ed's show the day before
and he done the rehearsal with one
audience at four and it in the rehearsal
Edie had beckoned him over at the end of
his song and that if you remember was
the greatest accolade in American show
business if they had liked your song and
beckoned you over Jose Feliciano said he
once did it to him and there was this
terrible long pause before ed really did
it that day because then when he got
Jose over he said Jose has really
overcome his handicaps he's not only
blind he's Puerto Rican a million
letters from Puerto Rico they're still
answering at the moment anyway anyway
Bette Bette and Jack Jones over and
sister Jack Jones on the rehearsal what
wasn't Alan Jones your father and Jack
said he still is
and after rehearsal ed said hey that was
very good let's keep it in tonight Jack
said okay it's your shadow okay sure
okay so that night and the end of his
song it beckons him over and says his
Alan Jones still your father I mean what
do you say one day on a Monday night
Easter day after Easter Joan Rivers was
still action on the Monday night because
she'd been on the Easter Sunday program
this was about 1970 this particular one
and it had been a very religio show that
show that Easter Sunday night and it is
opened with Eddie Albert reading the
Bible and then the West Point glee club
had sung a religious song and at the end
of the song ed had said quote the West
Point glee club ladies and gentlemen
they're off to Vietnam tomorrow and many
of them will probably never be coming
back and now it's comedy time with Joan
Rivers
I mean would you get on in a
circumstance private
he was once doing appeal for funds to
fight tuberculosis and he said and
remember help stamp out TV maybe he was
right about that but the but the
actually I remember I was the worst one
it was Richard her English guy mr. pace
to me his name was and he's got one
particular bit of shtick called the
Lancers and he'd been in the twenty two
twenty three years the Ed Sullivan Show
this was the last year he'd been on
twenty eight times it was twenty ninth
time and he said what would you like me
to do mr Sutherland he said the Lancers
oh no he wanted to do something he said
please let me do something else but the
only shower ever been on in America and
people in America are going to think
that this is the only thing I can know
but a sort of compromise was worked out
whereby Edie would introduce him and say
analysis and the twenty ninth time we're
delighted to have Richard here mister
pastry what have you got for us tonight
Richard and Richard was a way and I
thought I'd start with a song then do a
dance and end with some juggling and Ed
would say oh no please do my favorite
the Lancers method alright then to you
Ed I'll do that so ed would get what he
wanted but at least the seeds of
versatility had been sown in the minds
of the great American public so there
they are alive that evening as here is
29,000 richard her mister pastry what
have you got for us tonight Richard and
Richard said well and I thought I'd
start with a song then do a dance and
end with some juggling and Ed said fine
leaving Rich's hands hands aiyah please
let me do the lancers it's the only
thing I know anyway our tribute our
tribute to Ed Sullivan and now my
tribute to our panel we've got a
terrific panel and I'll read out the
names of the five members of panel and
then we'll ask you to welcome them with
the thunderous ovation that they so
justly deserve
Michael Kuhn is with us the president
and CEO of Polygram filmed entertainment
Peter Bart is joining us
the vice president editor-in-chief a
variety in daily variety and interviewer
- Michael Eisner and Harvey Weinstein is
here co-chairman of Miramax Films Linda
Oakes who of course is the producer
representing the production community
Linda opes productions and Jonathan
Dalton the chairman of Viacom
Entertainment Group who is working at
the moment to try and see how you can do
a sequel to Titanic and we'd like you to
welcome them all to join us here to talk
about the movies
there wasn't a plasma but now there is
Michael there's a place over here there
we are welcome to welcome to you all and
let's let's begin with the the Titanic
effects Michael let me start with you
what looks at me in horror what is going
to be the effect of the enormous success
of Titanic I think Rob limited actually
because the film business is strewn with
examples of really phenomenal movies
both of the low-budget end and the high
budget end and I think those of us who
work every day in the movie business
recognize them as one-off phenomenon and
I don't think it has any real long-term
effect such on what most of us on the
podium here do every day of the week not
that much of it Harvey do you think
people are gonna try and copy I'm gonna
think that megapix are the way to go
not Unisys I don't know about that but I
think Jonathan Dolch and Peter Chernin
bill mechanics should get a big raise
you know there actually is quite an
extraordinary phenomenon and as Michael
Eisner would say right now at all the
test previews with respect to tiny hat
the Titanic I was speaking yesterday to
the worldwide president of marketing at
Fox he said in the past 10 previews that
he's gone to sneak previews when the
focus group afterwards is asked why they
rated the movie excellent or very good
and they're just 25 hands going up for
very good and he said why didn't she
wait it is excellent and the entire
focus group says will it's not the
Titanic and I'm actually kind of worried
about it in the sense that I think the
bar has been raised not necessarily on
the kinds of pictures that Harvey does
or the kinds of pictures that Michael so
sick
well he does but in with respects to do
pictures where we're forced to pay top
star dollar and deliver entertainment
you know with massive marketing at
tentpole times of the year I think the
bar has been raised in physical
production and and I also think the bar
has been raised in terms of being able
to say no to directors we've just given
enormous applause on the highest
possible scale that we award to a person
who went wildly over budget in pursuit
of a dream and in the American Way we
reward that dream but it's going to be
very hard the next time a director says
to us I want more I want another 10 days
I want another 10 weeks I want another
five months I want another ten million
dollars to come up with the argument of
why Jim Cameron can't and he can and he
can't I'm well I'm more a little more
concerned than Michael Peter do you
think that Hollywood will resist this
this copying I mean we saw it with
things like The Sound of Music led to a
number of mega musicals which didn't
succeed particularly well do you think
people will go on regardless or they
will be affected well if you notice the
tendency to emulate in the blockbuster
business last year there were two
volcano pictures one of which kill the
other off this week there's a network
asteroid television movie which will be
followed this summer the two big
blockbuster the summer both concern
asteroids about to strike the earth
I think the Titanic distorts things in
the sense that the blockbuster business
the tentpole business at the Studios is
actually a kind of shoddy shape there
seems to be an absence of discipline and
absence of fresh ideas tendency to
imitate things are not happy
Jonathan well imitation is a problem I
hold the mic a bit closer Jonathan again
I get to say you're actually asking me
to speak louder
sure no I I guess the observation is the
part of the problem in the business and
there is sometimes a tendency to emulate
almost as if it were some sort of force
of nature but that doesn't last for long
because it's trying to figure it can
decide what you want to do creatively
based on what's happened before is kind
of like driving a car and trying to
figure out where you're going by looking
in the rearview mirror it won't take you
very far and and I guess people will say
things like that but I don't think we'll
take them very far it's certainly
creatively what principles do you
generalize from when we copy the box
office what are what are we gonna copy
here is it more movies on boats is it
movies have to be of an epic scale is it
the American Dream gloopy love story is
working again or is it simply the teen
market is given a romantic story in a
muscle context and I think one thing to
copy Linda is this that Titanic proved
one thing above all and that is that
special effects do not have to be used
in twister or or speed to that you can
tell a personal story with effects and
this could indeed have a somewhat
radical effect that's my future the
business do you think there's too little
romance then in movies I mean that the
romance ingredient was important here do
you think Hollywood is too slow to
indulge in romance hobby no I don't
think there's you're slow but I think
that it obviously worked and uh you know
I think that anytime you imitate you is
it's a prescription for failure you know
this happened it was a spectacular
success you know a Gone with the Wind
happened and you know I don't I don't
know maybe they made Jezebel or I don't
know that was before or after but you
know knowing rushes out and says alright
let's come make twenty Civil War movies
because Gone with the Wind worked I
think you just have to say this was a
phenomenon these two studios paramount
of Fox marketed it brilliantly and they
deserve a tremendous amount of success
what they have done is raise the the
poll for how much money you mean a movie
can gross you know so the potentiality
now has all changed and that's exciting
for the
but go out and you know say alright
let's have a teen love story you know I
mean said it and you know in the middle
of a volcano that destroys you know
complain please
anybody asks were there any kids on the
Lusitania don't invest with you I've
gotten three NOAA pitches you know but
but you know it's an interesting
question about romance because only
three weeks before Titanic opened I had
a great conversation with Nora Ephron
who was talking about the death of
gloopy love stories that you couldn't
really do for these romantic melodrama
anymore and if they were straightforward
gloopy love stories they just wouldn't
work and romance had moved into the
romantic comedy genre so by and large
you told romantic stories you played war
or you played house right and you told
romantic stories and romantic comedies
and teen girls would go and play house
and they would drag along their dates
and you could get some weekend business
out of it but what Titanic is very
interesting is a gloopy love story that
you allow yourself to enjoy as a
teenager because it's inside this
muscular effect structure because
there's something cool production-wise
it has the right stuff somehow so it
doesn't feel like a girl's movie and so
you don't have to Club the boy over the
head with the pole to get him to come
that weekend you know and and I think
maybe what that means is there's some
kind of mixed genre happening you know
Lusitania with it not quite Lusitania
not necessarily a more vote but effect
there any kids on the Bismarck what
about the business one of the other
trends where the big blimp what about
the question of partnerships we you were
mention how he was mentioning there
obviously Fox and paramount on this
Michael Eisner was talking about not
having partners on Armageddon does the
idea of partnerships appeal to you as a
trend Michael with other studio I think
I think if you get the order of
priorities right the order of priorities
are how many movies can I make 100%
myself and believe in and finance
because if you believe in the movie make
it if you don't believe in it sharing
that not belief won't help you very much
having said that once you've got your
core base number of new
these together you can finance you
believe in your gonna bet on the upside
and you're going to take the downside
and it's your neck on the line then and
over and above that there's tons of
movies to be done on a partnership basis
which gives you a bigger portfolio more
strikes of bat and that's very helpful
and that's why we've done partnerships
whether its individual pickups like on a
spice world movie or Trainspotting or
deal recently with Castle Rock with
Warner's on Castle Rock but they're over
and above what we consider to be our
core base of movies that we are going to
bat for and I think the worst reason and
so often when I have discussions with
other Studios the reason they want to
partner is because they don't really
believe in the project so why should I
believe in the project or anyone else
and to share a loss is no great business
philosophy now are you planning more
such partnerships John yes it makes it
makes sense when Michael's exactly right
if it's the picture is not a good movie
and you don't like the idea it doesn't
become better by having half of it I
mean that's not logical so you have to
kind of like creatively whatever you're
doing for us it made sense from just as
describing it's really a portfolio
observation about it if you had money to
manage and he decided you want to be in
a stock market would you have one stock
maybe I wanted bonds would you have one
bond would you I mean it's just a notion
of the economic side of the creative
observation is that you really probably
want a from our point of view diversify
diversify how much money you put out in
a variety of ways and configurations and
try to take a somewhat different
economic look at the structure so for us
we make the it's one hundred percent
correct like the creative observation is
what's got to be made first and then
secondarily we try to in our minds put
in some sort of a economic mix where we
run the range of 100 percent financing
the films are just distributing it for a
fee and inside that meld of all the
things we're trying to do try to make
good economic sense create a good
economic envelope in which they put the
the creative enterprise and if the gift
of it is true
sorry javi I wasn't tight with the gift
wasn't decided why share I've enjoyed
working with you know Jonathan and Shari
on the talented mr. Ripley which Anthony
Minghella who did English Patient is
going to do next
Matt Damon and then it's all the pretty
horses and we're gonna do with Sony and
I think what's really interesting is you
meet your competition I mean you just
see that they're terrific people you
know and you say my god what are we
fighting for and I it opens up doors and
other lines of communication so there's
a side benefit to it as well and I think
you know um I don't know two heads
sometimes do work better than one
because somebody comes up with a great
idea
you're sure he comes up with a great
idea of a script in and then we're all
the mutual you know you know
beneficiaries of it so it's a good check
and balance to have people who do
exactly what you do you know worked on a
project together I'm enjoying it and in
fact I mean oh we're talking about here
with the mega budgets and so on I mean
at the other end of the scale I mean
everybody is not everybody but most
people are having nice organizations and
so on to try and exploit that the
cheaper picture and so on and I mean
that's always been where you began do
you feel all those people are sort of
copying you Harvey I feel like Israel
and everybody is the six hour of Nations
little Perez now I feel good more I
press but we have a good Air Force and a
good Mossad Peter do you think before we
leave Titanic completely do you think
there's anything sociological to learn
in the success of the film people always
like to analyze this shows that we are a
nation that once is looking for this or
that quite a powerful kind of very
well-made film and all of that do you
think it says anything about a loss of
romance or the loss of ships or whatever
I think it says something about that
there are so many teenage girls in the
United States who clearly have to get a
life
but apart from that you know the war the
one thing about what we're talking about
in terms of the niche pictures the one
thing about the Titanic that was
troubling to me is that in the last
three months it had this extraordinarily
clear corridor namely I don't think
anybody at this table could name any
pictures that opened up against it many
of them were some of them would deal
pictures some where the law would be
wannabe niche pictures but the fact that
they were at a time when there's
supposed to be this extraordinary glut
of film that there could be three months
on the calendar when there's nothing
that would sail along to challenge this
thing that to me was rather depressing
but all waiting for my next picture to
come out so they could bunch up around
that I don't know I saw terrific movie
US Marshals I really like that movie
there was a good popcorn movie and I
thought it was as good as the fugitive I
just think the Titanic just you know
creamed it you know I can't I think for
exactly what Linda's saying you know you
start to say okay welcome compared for
that entertaining audience not the you
know movie in the movies that Miramax
traditionally makes or the movies of
Polygram makes it's hard to you know to
live with that I mean and I'll tell you
the other effect is I know that we
pulled scream 2 out of foreign I mean
Titanic is doing a hundred million
dollars in France and Germany were set
to open in March so let's get the hell
out of there I mean you know we're going
in April in May you know you just we
abandon ship you know it's interesting
sociological a is that I've had a lot of
conversations this week about how vapid
Titanic was and how empty it was and how
it was just this thing for teenagers and
then last night I heard Stanley Crouch
make the best argument for Titanic I've
heard all along in terms of theme and I
don't think it's just teenage girls who
need a life although the rebellious
teenage daughter is a myth that will not
die right there's a lot of American
myths in Titanic that really work there
is it's a pro-immigrant at a time where
it's sort of an anti-immigration kind of
feeling it's very pro-immigrant it's
very pro-american dream it's very the
lower-class can take on the upper class
its entitled in the upper class of some
how corrupt and the moment where
Leonardo DiCaprio takes the helm of his
boat and says this is my boat and owns
it is a moment of great sort of mythic
engagement and I feel the sort of whoosh
go through the audience at that moment
of owning that lack of passivity it's
almost a kind of conservative reaction
against that post modern facility you
see in teenagers it's this is my boat
this is my life I'm gonna make something
of it and that's the American dream - it
has a rocky quality in that sense and
you can't kill that myth with a stick he
actually made a great movie and it's
something to do with it as well no more
just a perfect for me I mean it's
nothing is ever perfect you can you go
into the Sistine Chapel you say a little
more blue I think I have a sign but it's
a it's a it's a it's a perfect thing I
mean as constructed I mean you may say a
little bit more blue whatever the
functional equivalent of that is but
he's made a perfect thing on its own
terms
it's totally engaging it's totally
overwhelming in some ways it uses
technology in a new and special way it
makes you feel very much a time in place
and it's it has great thematic resonance
amongst people not just here but every
place so I think that you have to as we
try to analyze and I've been reading
people analyzing why they didn't like it
over the last week I guess voting for
the minority these are these cities I
know I like these people by the way
because they were the six other folks of
water from a government along with me so
I felt some cultural affinity to them
but other than that I mean most most
people were engaged by this thing
because he did something very special
and I think we honored with our time and
it transcended not just the American
observations about it but the overseas
business means some of those very
American observations they're really
basic human came into basic human
emotions and he he did it he created a
very special thing and I think we're
honoring that with everybody playing
down the right bucks they try to see it
over and over again what about the
thought that came up this morning
that that in fact a two million dollar
film and the two hundred million dollar
film there should be different prices of
admission forms what what do you think
about that Michael rubbish rubbish why
well I didn't hear anyone complain about
being paid eight dollars for the two
million dollar movie and when I make a
movie such as mr. bean which is coming
on for two hundred fifty million dollar
grossed around the world that cost
seventeen million dollars why should I
be paid less because people enjoyed it
just as much as another movie that grows
two hundred fifty million dollars in
cost uh seventy million dollars to make
I mean I think it's a complete nonsense
argument the order observation would be
that you would pay for the the art
object based on how much paint and
bronze was used as opposed to how much
art and beauty was contained because
it's not a logical observation it's also
a slippery slope then we start bargain
and then we start bargaining off prices
of tickets for product I mean there's no
it's there's no there there it would
have one interesting benefit actually
have a studio of lying up the cost of
their films but other than that just
mischievous you know observation I can't
see anything
cute about it what did you think of the
fairy paper when you heard it well it
it's sort of surreal however you know
there was a time a generation ago where
there were Roadshow Pictures exclusive
runs even I think Andy may have been the
last one and and you know a picture like
The English Patient arguably could have
opened where in one city charged
reserved seats had an intermission it
needed an intermission charge charge a
lot more I mean City on a limited basis
to give the devil his due there may be
some some argument in in returning to
that traditional form of how do you feel
like well III think that you know I've
got cinema paradiso when we actually
have the director's cut of the movie
which
contrary to rumor we didn't cut but was
actually cut by a French his French
co-producer and I think we're gonna
experiment with that because it's three
hours and ten minutes and put an
intermission in and see what that does I
think one of the great things I agree
with Michael one of the great things
about going to the movies is you know
it's so democratic you just go into the
theater everybody pays the same price so
I mean it's one of those last bastions
of where you know there isn't a
corporate box and you know and you know
you don't have to feel excluded it's
just so accessible which is why it's the
most popular medium so I don't want to
you know lose that but I think when a
movie is really long sometimes maybe you
can make a special presentation and that
way you you subsidize the one
performance at night that you can get
you make it an intermission and I
disagree with Peter I thought the
English Patient was just fine and
grossed 220 million dollars around the
world talking of Europe that Harvey one
of the things is one of the trends is
you've done this and lots of studios
have done this is new links with
overseas entities or new entities
overseas as you've done in the UK and so
on what effect is that going to have on
you and what what effect it's going to
have on the way the Europeans make their
movies well
mirmix has recently done a deal with
three fabulous executives in England
TRAI Hoving Colin Leventhal and David
auch in two of whom ran films for very
successfully what it does for us is it
broadens our horizons it takes on
entrepreneurs like my brother and myself
who are traditionally terrible at
delegating and forces us to you know
learn proper administrative technique
and also to allow other people to bring
their creativity and autonomy you know
to the table so for me it's been
incredibly read you know not only
reassuring that you know I mean that it
can work both ways but just a
fascinating process because this is the
second part you know of our career and
now it's you know I mean either we just
megalomaniacal you know which worked for
the first 15 years or now start to
delegate and you know be a little bit
more statesman like John do you think
it's a good idea that those sort of link
ups with the foreign entities
it depends I'm not much for exact which
means those sort of I mean there's
obviously our businesses is an
international world business obviously
there's great talent outside the United
States so yes it makes it makes sense to
be involved the exact nature of the
arrangement I wouldn't go on to comment
on it cuz it can be in a variety of
arrangements I think that you know for
us we would expect to see an
increasingly vital European filmmaking
business hopefully with ideas that have
resonance past their own borders I think
it'll be good for good for everyone
revitalized some of those local cinema
businesses which is good for us as well
so we see nothing wrong with it and we
see it obviously as a place as place to
look for talent and ideas in a world
that which there were probably a limited
number of really good ideas what could
be wrong with it if you look at the
downside potentially it hasn't happened
yet is that here's a moment in history
where indigenous cinemas in many parts
of the world indigenous cinema is really
is really making an extraordinary
comeback it would be it would be a
tragedy at that moment if if the
Hollywood studios somehow imposed a
decision-making process on that which
which discouraged it or Hollywood eyes
did or whatever that conceivably could
happen I think whoever does that will
fail doing it and I think the idea would
be if you tried that I wouldn't say you
couldn't try I mean people people have
been through it we've not gone through
that cycle everybody having offices in
London and that cycle basically resulted
in huge economic loss for now for
everyone as they try to impose their
ideas and cost structures and creative
notions upon what was otherwise a a
well-run business so I think whoever
tries that won't point to well it how
how Michael how do you think you you
bring films of us into the States and so
on but a very worldwide business how
well our American film
sold around the world well I think
you've obviously been primed on this as
this is my particular hobby hobby horse
it's a remarkable fact that around the
world American movies are so incredibly
dominant at the box office much more
dominant than Anglo American music is
and yet when you go around the world the
structure of the Hollywood studios by
and large is so outdated compared to
what is required in today's world and I
speak without exception and in a world
when the maximization of revenues and
margins is paramount in the movie
business
when the manipulation of windows whether
its theatrical or pay or video should be
left to the lowest competent level that
is to say the national organization it's
completely amazing the disarray the lack
of thought lack of innovation that goes
into the studio's organizations
internationally and long may continue
and in fact I am about to write a letter
to the European Commission of begging
him to keep you IP in organizing in
operation for many years and I will
personally agree a subvention from
Polygram to ensure that this happens
should he decide to reverse his decision
on that matter do you think that do you
agree with that John I'd be delighted to
mail the letter for him I mean it's I
mean the observations are in the four
meetings in the international
marketplace the marketplace has
progressed so rapidly in size and scope
and changed so rapidly not just the size
of the business but the way business is
conducted the need for for marketing and
what we describe as America and American
terms with American spending levels in
Lhasa at least two or three major
territories and in some respects the
organization's as all human
organizations is trailing it's not
operating on a real
based on the vendor change I think the
organizations out there that are good
are seeking to are seeking to bring
themselves current with with with market
conditions and the good ones will do
well because of that and the ones who
don't change quickly enough will will do
less well I think that's that's not
general observation okay one of the
things that I like about what Polygram
is doing is as a I think British based /
Dutch based company they bring things
like mr. bean or the borrower's things
that you know a part of the cultural the
Anglo cultural their own background and
then mount use techniques to mass-market
those movies so in a sense they
introduced us into new characters new
stars and I think that's just forgetting
the profit-loss aspect of this I just
think that's exciting because it
reinvents the business if Titanic is an
old new idea and so is mr. bean because
it's like Laurel & Hardy or
I mean you know it goes back to the
greatest traditions of our business and
at the st. which is a great clown doing
what great clowns do and then it also is
just so uniquely you know new in the
last 20 years so I'm hope that our
British team isn't saying let's make
Huckleberry Finn you mean other which
they're not going to be doing but finds
that thing that's intrinsic you know and
brings it forward and that's what's
exciting to me do you think in fact this
people often write about how they'll be
under 20 million dollars and over 75
million dollars as if as if there's no
film's in the middle is there any any
truth to that people that sort of
predictions I mean and they're
endangered but there's sort of nuts any
such thing it's very difficult to make a
20 million dollar studio film there's
maybe with the new teen market there
there will be a way without movie stars
of making studio movies between 15 and
12 and 20 million dollars but by and
large if you are going to drive an idea
to the marketplace what I call an
endangered specie an ocean as opposed to
a high concept not a tentpole but a
script you need movie stars in order to
do it and movie stars don't cut their
price for the major
studios and it drives you to you know 20
above the line before you even get going
and so a small script becomes a thirty
five million dollar movie forty million
dollar movie sixty million dollar movies
have become average an enormous part of
that until the Titanic production factor
just kicked in an enormous obviously
question of that is the star power that
it takes to open a character-driven
movie because studios aren't in the
platforming business you know by and
large so um I do fear for the middle
level movie the sadly or or ironically
the thing that seems to be saving the
endangered species movie is the teen
market because the stars that are being
replenished are less expensive because
they haven't opened that many movies yet
and three more movies we won't be able
to afford them and they'll become thirty
five million dollar movies but
interestingly it's well Harvey and his
brother helped find that market for us
unfortunately on the week I had a movie
opening it's it's these movies can be
made for a price right now inside the
studio system and the question is once
we identify those stars who reliably
open movies their prices will rise and
those will become thirty million dollar
movies all over again
so it's to me it's a problem and and
it's one of the reasons making movies
with a Polygram or Miramax is very
attractive or a searchlight and we're
starting these smaller divisions because
there's possibly a way in which we can
get talent to reduce their prices and
therefore make movies in the responsible
way that the smaller companies are able
to do do you know instance that you're
fighting an everlasting battle and
sometimes losing battle against
escalating costs and talent costs and so
on yeah I think you're you're you're
locked in this and this and this issue
of how to run your business against a
rising tide of costs that you can solely
control because there is someone else
who may pay a price that that escalates
that escalates the cost what you want
otherwise pay for free so town we had
that experience last year there was a
piece of talent
wouldn't pay more than X and having done
that within 36 hours someone paid him
not what we said no to but a price in
excess of what we had said no to and so
you know we didn't make the movie didn't
make money all right we didn't make the
movie that's well but but so you do deal
in that world I mean it's driven by you
know basic you know Adam Smith there are
you know the you and when you feel list
these star power the would you would to
feel with stars would open a film and
the number of films that would make in
any year you're gonna come to a number
that's no more than 15 movies and there
are a hundred and sixty movies roughly
speaking and being released by the
majors and more than 400 screens each
year that leaves an awful lot of movies
that those 15 that those folks can't be
in which is also driving up a level of
prices for everyone else so I think that
we I'd like to believe in Adam Smith's
sense that the the the economic reality
will have come the studio's will come to
grips of that economic reality and we'll
probably see someone lessening of those
number of films which will have a
salutary impact on not on the you know
the real real stars but on that the
price level below it which will make it
more likely that somebody's other films
gonna be made the difficulty was making
some of these other films is that I mean
some of these observations like all
conventional wisdom I mean the English
translation that conventional wisdom
could be that under ten or fifteen
million dollars how much can you lose
okay so it takes creative pressure off
you and over eighty million dollars you
have a star so you feel you'll be
guaranteed something in it and some are
in the netherworld you actually have to
make the picture and people have to work
on concept and script and casting and
marketing in a more difficult way but I
think people actually would have had
success with that and I don't really
people I don't really believe that
people are honing to that conventional
wisdom as much as people would like to
say about we have a lot of success of
the last year the conventional wisdom is
in crisis right now because the movie
stars who make twenty million dollars a
picture aren't systematically opening
pictures I mean that's the crisis of the
studio system this year is that it's not
automatic if you pay twenty million
dollars that your baby boomer generation
movie star is going to open that movie
and you're in the near of megabuck
blockbusters in the ID for Godzilla
Titanic era which does not require movie
stars so you have a new star being
production you have reliable stars who
are the only ones that can give any
degree of comfort for an experimental or
and not necessarily commercial
blockbuster kind of script and those
guys aren't necessarily doing it there's
a glut of reliance on them that's made
the audience a little bit more skeptical
unintelligent and discerning and the
choices it's making Lynda there's a glut
period yeah that's the worst part of it
you know if the movie stars are
unreliable at opening pictures it's
because they're faced with eight movies
we I mean and and it's not even the
eight movies a week it's just the fact
that three of them were the same theme
well you know I went with the same
audience trying it to the same audience
and you know three thrillers open within
two weeks of each other I mean you come
out of distribution and marketing
meetings today and your team says to you
look I think I can find a week run you
mean you know that I'm clean and and you
know what happens they're celebrating
the fact that they can put a romantic
comedy on June 17th you know and there's
not three other romantic comedies that
weekend forget that there's three
romantic comedies the weekend before and
three coming up ahead but they said wow
we landed you mean you know somebody's
doing a big action movie that day you
know so we can sneak the romantic comedy
and I mean that the distribution
schedule looks like a minefield combined
with the chessboard and it's just taking
unbelievable skills you know to to dance
through that particular situation and
it's driving up marketing costs enormous
Lee the only way you can compete with no
in a glut and the glut of movies is by
by a glut of marketing so whose signal
is strongest to get through the noise
that's money and that once again Rises
it raises the costs of the whole
enterprise exponentially well takes you
back to that Jack Valenti's number that
was cited this morning I mean if the
typical picture costs 75 million to
produce and market that this is daunting
in the sense
that it discourages the risk-taking
process you go with those stars even as
Linda says stole stars who have proven
they can't open a picture simply because
at those numbers you can't afford to
take risks and history is certainly
proven that if you can't take risks
you're really asking for it
where did where does Jack Valenti get
these figures from Harvey does that your
average that's my budget for a year I
think someone should have a word with
Jack Valenti and explains him that when
he band is these figures around it gives
us incredible problems with these guys
here and most that when you look at his
movies in my mood I don't wear these
figures come on Michael Michael those
are probably major studio figures and
they're probably true you know I arrived
at 23 million dollars per studio movie
marketing average Michael I bet that's
true because when you say no the movie
costs 50 and there's another 25 on the
average marketing movie I see some of
those figures I mean you know the
studio's spent 40 50 million dollars of
market some yeah baby look well then
when I could play it out all I can say
is that the shows extreme lack of
discipline because on the on the movie
star side that we were just talking
about no one forces you to hire a twenty
million dollar player no one if you make
that choice I think whoever was
repeating that great remark of Sam
Goldwyn that he's overpriced but worth
it this morning was correct I mean there
are stars are you say giuse and then you
were happy Li write the check out there
but the thing that's completely
uncontrollable and remembering the days
when you started Harvey was it you could
take a movie out and you could do it
with no you could go and establish
word-of-mouth sue the MPAA do all the
tricks they used to do and you get a
movie open now it is impossible in you
couldn't do that again today and all
these startups at Paramount how the
universe they're all gonna have to spend
whether it's whatever it is money on
media on hard media and that is the
scary thing and that the lack of
discipline on the studio's on the amount
they spend on market
ratchets up the cost because there's no
way you can do anything if there's a
tremendous noise out there you have to
make yourself heard you afters no good
saying I refuse to spend it's nice to
open this movie you know a discipline
thing but it's not actually a discipline
thing it's really in some respects what
Linda was talking about Harvey we're
talking about as a market force thing
now some people aren't spending more
than they should but the stats when I
looked at him for last year and for the
year before were there were 19 weekends
last year in the year before on which I
four or more films opened on 400 or more
screens and 31 weekends on which there
were six films that opened that weekend
of the weekend before which still have
anything well the question I was asking
my marketing people and I'm sure you
asked yours is when they say there's no
weekend between now and 2014 the movie
is you say well how come for four weeks
last summer last for last spring I
couldn't find anything to go and see and
the answer is because when they count
all those movies 80% of them are rubbish
and if you've got something that works
through it it works through it and
that's the issue it's not how many
movies but how many movies the real
movies open in the weekend yes or no you
see at Taemin if you're opening it if
you're opening up two movies on a genre
if the bad movie takes four and you're
very opening a teen movie that's four
million dollars you're not taking that
weekend because they went to see that
other film and it has some impact on the
total economics I mean just can't that's
just just even if it's a bad movie I
mean a formula for me if you have four
million dollars worth of business that
money was otherwise gonna go someplace
but I never heard you I never heard any
of my marketing people say you know what
how many weeks is Titanic being out now
15 15 weeks out we're gonna have to
watch out for Titanic they never told me
that they will tell me that that
particular weekend like this one or the
one before there was so many other
movies that have been and gone and no
one's ever seen and since then no one
there Howell said that your movie was
playing and will be going up last
weekend Harvey yeah I mean it's when you
have a screen which is a teen
demographic that goes directly against a
Titanic on an international basis watch
out because you know we saw what
happened
you know we tested a market when we went
into Australia we opened into enormous
business but Titanic just sucks up the
whole you know markets we had that big
opening and then we just said look
adjust to the marketplace but then you
know then then these sort of adult
movies like Good Will Hunting and as
good as it gets
have just you know it's like stayed the
steady course with Titanic's 15 weeks
and we read the number three or four
they're five and we're six why don't we
just stay thank you you know it just
stayed the course
alright well let's do the want George
Bush called the vision thing from Evan
looking ahead to the to this conference
in ten years time I mean what is going
to be the shape what are going to be the
differences to the film business ten
years from now in the importance of
video in the nature of the theater
chains in it I mean what is going to
happen in the next ten years to move in
Harvey Peter Borik is gonna have a
little television show and he's gonna
host it and what's gonna happen is
instead of bidding on scripts the way we
now do we get them from agencies and
things like that
Peter's gonna host the show and he's
gonna have Quentin Tarantino and Jim
Cameron as his guests and we're just
gonna you know save costs and Dalton
myself you know Linda we're all gonna
have to bid you know he's gonna say
tonight's guest is Jim Cameron here's
the script like home shopping you know
so we're gonna be sitting in our pajamas
I mean you know as the next script comes
up that's what I think that's a great
rhythm Linda wants yogurt well you know
I don't even understand the hardware of
today I'm not really a hardware person
and I have not I need three assistants
to help get me online so I really don't
understand hardware but I do have a
sense a little sense of software just
because I read a lot and my sense from
the market I read a wonderful quote in
Vanity Fair this week that said this the
baby boomers who are now running this
thing and making all these decisions and
have been probably for a decade now more
and more are the generation the culture
that that thought they would always rule
and they turn around and discover they
thought there would never be another
culture and they turn
and discover there is and I think what's
happening is that we are going to cede
to whatever it comes after us the
software is going to the hands of the
generation that follows us it's very
different
there are children we'll be making
movies for our children and that has
something to do with technology they
were wired they were born on the net and
they were born with affects their first
movie was toys you know and they've they
are a different market than we are and I
think we're gonna have a hard time
adjusting and learning and and
regulating the taste of boomers is going
to see to the taste of their children
and so for a software point of view it's
interesting that's very interesting
Michael what are you projecting for the
next ten years and starting to take note
of now well the first thing I'm a
tremendous optimist about the movie
business when you look at the future I
think the one thing that everyone has a
good deal of consensus on is the
importance of the digital revolution and
for once those catchphrases are hard to
argue with it's digital and it will be
revolutionary and it's here now and when
you look at that and you say well what
are the important constituent parts of
that as far as content is concerned
someone said this morning content is you
don't watch digital you watch the
content on digital and if you analyze
what content there is there's
information content and there's
entertainment content and if you look at
the information content that has certain
rather whirring things about it while it
can boom tremendously it combust
tremendously as well and has no residual
value so if someone comes up with a
newer better faster sexier cheaper
version of Bloomberg have a big and
successful Bloomberg is they can
disappear tomorrow without any residual
value on the other hand if you look at a
film library which has being proved over
the years you can have a company that's
run into the ground for 20 years like as
it was being detailed by Peter in his
book on MGM and the thing still sells
but probably more than was ever spent on
the movies in the
first place when it comes on the market
again in the entertainment area and
there's a further distinction that needs
to be made and that is the difference
between filmed entertainment and
specially Hollywood filmed entertainment
which is unique in it has a huge
worldwide attractiveness and the other
very very important piece of
entertainment content which is sport
which by its nature is regional local
and even those who thought there was
such a thing as European soccer have
been somewhat disappointed realizing
that the British may like Italian soccer
but they don't give a toss about German
soccer and so on and so if you look in
the if you if you agree that the digital
revolution is important and if you want
to say what is that what are the main
beneficiaries of that going to be its
content and what sort of content will
information content are undoubtedly
important but it's less a less better
bet than the than the filmed
entertainment a content which is a
better bet than sports which you can't
own anyway and there are only six or
seven suppliers of that Hollywood
content in the world and the demand
growing as it's growing at the moment is
just fantastic and I think as long as we
can be
disciplined in our financials and make
sure that we turn a profit the value
growth will be spectacular and the
opportunities are just tremendous and I
think that a conference ten years from
now will need the whole six or seven
times the size of this one to
accommodate all the people interested
and wanted to learn about filmed
entertainment thank you very much indeed
one of the other interesting things
where sports magnifying its takings in
Britain at the moment most of the money
is going straight to the players just
absolutely direct talking of talent fees
and so on but I mean straight isn't it
to some of the players are getting three
million instead of half a million and so
on Peter what's your vision 10 years
from now well I took Harvey's offer
already so I don't need a vision but my
I think that maybe 10 years from now
that there this this tacit bifurcation
that exists in the industry today
whereby they're the tentpole pictures
which make all money and Harvey's domain
that this will be somehow
institutionalized so that insofar as the
process of choosing which blockbusters
to make it'll be done democratically all
the fast-food companies and the other
tie-in partners the toy people and so
forth we allowed to vote on screenplays
Zuma gets a vote the Dodgers get a vote
that's only fair and therefore that
would be a more democratic and
representative way of choosing the
wannabe blockbusters and then then
Harvey be left to make his pictures on
the other end of the spectrum and the
industry will live very happily happily
ever after John will they will the
industry live happily ever after in ten
years time absolutely thank you good
night I was really and he's got the
profits to prove it we get to be with
everything Michael said except put the
shot of a German soccer yeah I don't
know it doesn't have something British
to be there to get that I don't
understand that I mean ten years out ten
years out ten years out a couple things
probably true put aside that you know
the the digital stuff for a while and
this matter which way it is you probably
assume that there'll be an extraordinary
growth in just in the pure dollar value
and a need for for the kind of product
that we create the entertainment product
that we create some there made reference
to the growth of theaters
internationally that's certainly true
ten years out easy to see a double to
triple the size of that business outside
that's outside this country particularly
outside of Europe where I think it's
only only really begun begun to take
root and all of the you know the digital
transmission technologies will probably
bring some more dollars back to us as
manufacturers of that product
you'd probably expect at that point in
time if you're 10 years out now 10 years
out no one can be wrong because it's not
going to come back and be called on this
three years we might be but 10 years out
you would expect to hope that you'd be
seeing some more participation potential
awakening giant insight some of the
European operations and companies who
begin to see that as something they
should be interested in which they
should be doing either on their own or
in coordination cooperation with some of
us some of the American companies to do
that as well I don't think the fast food
company is going to get a vote I sorted
out with us
I don't think we ought to be letting the
fans food companies and the tie-ins one
of these sure ways no you're gonna lose
money is if they start talking about the
sequel before they talk about the first
movie or they start talking about the
merchandising before they talk about the
movie then you know you're in trouble
you might as well set yourself on fire
that's the best thing that's gonna
happen me that year with that
observation 10 years out sure
everything'll be great well I don't
thank you all for that very very
interesting and witty view of 10 years
from now I'm sure everybody will make
one of seven thousand reservations for
10 years from now as Michael predicts in
this vast Madison Square Garden it will
be held in 10 years time but we do have
time for one or two questions from the
folks here so we'd love to hear from you
I know they've solved all the problems
for the next time but here is a question
hello go ahead okay Mary and Rufus Hurst
I'm stunned that no one mentioned the
gerontological boom the fact that there
are teens doesn't negate the fact that
there are going to be millions and
millions of people in the odd couple 10
I just generated and although they may
not seem now to spend the money they
will then because they're now trained
into going to the film's every day or
two days or every week and they will
expending money so not to have a vision
any of the five of the panelists
absolutely amazes me nobody questioned
well not really what I didn't mention in
the teen argument because so far what
I've discovered unfortunately is that
it's very rare that the boomers even at
40 let alone 60 and 70 go drive first
weekend movie business because they're
busy because they can rent a movie
because they have a tremendous amount of
middle class other issues they're not
driving first weekend business which
more and more the business is driven by
now I can't imagine and I look forward
to a time when we're not driven by first
late weekend business and I certainly
look forward to being in my 60s and
going out every Friday night and this
reversing itself but in trying to make
pictures for grownups and then trying to
make pictures for women even in their
40s it's been an enormous problem to me
the degree to which our generation rents
and they did and when they're properly
backed up for in and out they show up if
you they show up sometimes if you beckon
them properly if you think you know I
think there is a movie going habit there
there is also a growing a growing
audience older and if the terrible thing
is the TV demo say it's 30 you know was
a 35 and over so that you and your agent
great-grandmother in the same target
demo depressing observation but there is
an increasing residence in that business
particularly female today and 10 years
out it would certainly be true that the
movie-going habit that had been lost by
the feed people who are now in their
sixties is definitely a trend that's you
know a habit of stayed with people when
there
late 40s in the the boomers late 40s
early 50s and one would have every
reason to expect that that movie going
habit is something is going to continue
particularly in a changed motion picture
viewing environment with better with
better multiplexes offering offering
more for you you would see that that
would be something that that that you
would expect would happen and their kids
will be grown up and out and not able to
go to those movies on the first weekend
so they will be right thank you
next please yes sorry hey Edgar Bronfman
mentioned the fractionalization of the
distribution and the many nodes that
would be available when we go digital
what what ways our Studios using to
protect themselves and their content
when every you know and everyone has an
opportunity to distribute this material
what does that mean are you talking
about cut all right we're going to tell
you about Tyra and copyright and
pirating and big issue
I mean I think that the industry worries
about on the industry but we worry about
standards we worry about ante competeing
copying devices as we deal with the the
so-called DVD issues we're dealing with
we're very much concerned with the
issues which deal with regionalization
on the machine on the disk anti copying
anything copying the devices what things
that they call watermarking which
prevent the copying of the item I mean
it's very important for us I think you
know if we blow that and the notion that
it's once you've done it once it's out
there and it's free it takes whole there
would be there would be banned for us
however we do live in an environment
today where given the current state of
technology there's an awful lot of
piracy and we spend an awful lot of time
trying to police that and a moderately
successful in certain parts of the world
less less successful than others thank
you very much yes Hillary cranker
megamax we've been able to attract Frank
Marshall and Kathleen Kennedy to the
large-format business more commonly
known as IMAX to produce the film
Olympic glory which is the first-ever
film on the Olympics dunnan's
new millimeter and my question to to all
of you is will any of the studios step
forward to produce films in the IMAX
format we've been able as I said to
attract top Hollywood producers to our
film but we're curious to see what kind
of collaboration we can put together
with one of you who'd like to take that
one Harvey I'm sure the IMAX format is a
fantastic format to work on and aren't
you doing one there's a Star Trek
there's a possibility that an
impossibility I'm sorry but I think it's
an expensive format to work in Sony did
two films they're not here today with a
the two films that they financed in the
imax format I don't know how well
they've done economically on those but
so there is some some interest in it can
I first something after the panel yeah
do you guys ever get signed contracts
and then all of a sudden the talent that
you helped make ask for big
renegotiations and success with sign
contracts I've never got a signed
contract I knew I was doing something
wrong
one other thing talking of Billy Billy
Christian that was then this is now
somebody here we go to mine my name is
Barbara Russell from Oppenheimer
um could you comment on how increasingly
the actors that we see emerging in the
film industry have been incubated by the
television industry and how that might
have implications in the future for a
paradigm shift in the net worth getting
involved in theatrical production Sunday
you mean like Clint Eastwood
I think that we basically will
cannibalize talent from anywhere that it
works now there used to be a kind of
hierarchical snob ISM towards television
and you went there when you couldn't get
a feature anymore and now basically our
hunt for for talent with Heath it
doesn't cost twenty million dollars has
taken us obviously to breaking
television shows because televisions
more interesting than it ever has been
to rock stars to international stars the
the stars are breaking globally you know
from Jackie Chan to in McGregor to all
the adorable Australian boys who broke
this year Guy Pearce and those guys I
think basically the movie industry hunts
everywhere trolls every corridor for
popularity for charisma for potential
new movie stars particularly in the
early bargain-hunting
phase of their careers we hired George
Clooney for his first lead role and his
price quadrupled in the movie
subsequently and more important Linda
Jerry Springer just made a movie deal I
heard that actually that's what the
ending is they're doing a Jerry Springer
movie in fact she's doing the Bible he's
doing know exactly shorter fewer
Commandments thou shalt not omit
adultery but Tokyo the told you the
Billy Crystal's great line at the Oscars
about isn't it funny that a year ago
Washington was complaining about there
being too much sex in Hollywood right
and that was Billy Crystal at the Oscars
but I mean how does Hollywood have your
behave do you think this year everybody
complains about too much sex too much
violence how have you all behaved this
year do you think nobody's a big bore in
Hollywood now everybody's a big bore in
Hollywood really they just work and go
home and pass out they barely make it to
their questions asked a personal
question I think you meant on the screen
there's still a big bore oh yes hobby
you can to President Clinton's I think
yeah I'm sure we're gonna have something
you know come up by a you know spring or
summer that will get us into you know
hot water it's how I work it out with
Jack Valenti every year you know this is
we're on a plan
so it's you know whenever I need to have
a little of excitement I just put it
into the corner so there's a movie
artemisia that about the artists that
could be maybe some will think is very
very sexy and it's very very artistic so
it's the perfect excuse to go out there
movies absolutely well ladies and
gentlemen I'm sure you'll agree with me
that both in terms of their thoughts
about the future and their wit and humor
our panel have given us of a marvelous
afternoon
ladies and gentlemen thank you very much